[موسيقى]
كانت طبيعه الرسم تبعتي شويه هيك بسيطه
فيها الاشكال بطريقه عفويه الوجوه الكبير
الاجسام الصغيره
زي كل الاطفال طبعا ببدا ارسم برصاص
وبالوان وهيك نفس الخيال اللي كان عندي
وانا صغيره صرت احاول اخليه انه انفذه على
الواقع بس بهذا العمر المواضيع اللي كتير
يعني بركز عليها الرجال والست اكثر شيء
الطيور بحب انه في عندي اكمن رمز هم اكثر
شي بشتغل عليهم يعني
[موسيقى]
بدات بشكل كتير بسيط بالجرائد الاردنيه
بالحبر طبعا كانت اول مرحله لالي بعدين
بديت شوي شوي امسح من اللون الاسود وابدا
اضيف الالوان يعني حتى كانت هيك مرحله
تدريجيه بعتبرها
بحب اجسد مواقف ما بين الاشخاص بالحياه
بحب الجوانب الانسانيه بحب اركز عليها
كثير في الحياه بشكل عام بعدين في مرحله
ثانيه اللي هي لا صرت ارسم خلص انه اجسد
الطفوله اكثر البراءه اكثر
الاشياء اللي شوي يمكن احنا بهذا الوقت
صرنا نفتقدها يعني بصراحه
الواني قبل كانت مندفعه كتير
لنقول الناريه اكثر هلا مع الوقت بتصير
فعلا من كتله المشاكل اللي بتسمعها بتلاقي
اللون فعلا بدها شوي شوي يخف
انا بلحق خيالي الفني اللي ما في كثير
قيود ما في في حريه بالنفس حريه بالفكر
مشان هيك يمكن خطوطي عفويه بسيطه فيها
هالبراءه كتير عاليه
الرضا عن النفس بخلي البني ادم يعيش
ببراءه بنقاء روحي
بخليه يعيش بسعاده داخليه
[موسيقى]